you're the guy from brozone we were just
listening to
them baby
Branch but that's all in the past Branch
how come you never told me you had a
secret brother correction used to be my
brother my brothers walked out on me and
never came back Branch we're out of sink
we've gone from Boys to Men and now
there's only one direction for us to go
the back streets it all does start with
the story so what was the inspiration
for trolls band together you know from
the ge-o we were always talking about
Branch's backstory his family expanding
out the world we talked about how much
we wanted to do like the biggest baddest
best family reunion ever and just
expanding it out and having fun with it
and so it really started with all of us
just talking about our families and our
experiences with families and trying to
find the real true story and what that
was yeah we tried to get get as many
Dynamics in there as possible with your
siblings you could see yeah how how did
so so this obviously the story was
inspired by family but how how did it
sort of like paid it forward and and you
know like deepen your families oh it's
true we talk about that a lot Tim and I
had a lot of conversations like we
better uh you know act like we preach
about it and it did bring us closer to
our families you know but what's great
about the film is the importance of
family and how they are irreplaceable
but that it's hard it's hard to be in a
family and I like that the movie can
have that like it's not perfect yeah
speaking of of the pandemic you know we
started making this movie while we were
all still at home during coid and a lot
of us were were at home with our
families and surrounded by this group of
people whether it was sisters or spouses
and you know Brothers whatever um I
think we were all in such tight quarters
with the people closest to us that sort
of informed okay this story can be about
those kinds of Dynamics and the ups and
the downs and how um you know it's okay
to sort of go separate ways but then
come back together and realize that
everyone's grown and evolved and become
a different version of themselves and
that's that's a beautiful part of the
family experience I'm the youngest of
two other brothers uh by far like
there's a a decent Gap about 12 years
from me and my my other brother and and
even though I'm just turned 40 and I'm a
full you know I'm an adult now I like at
least I like to think I am um that you
know they still there's still that
Dynamic of of you know still kind of
treating me like I'm you know the
younger brother in a loving way but
still you know very much like you know
like they know how the world works and
I'm still you know learning and that
sort of thing they don't make you still
wear a diaper do they no God no no and
Benjamin I want to ask like you your
third go round with the trolls feature
so like like what were the challenges
for you to expand that those characters
and and also bring in a whole new look
for some of the these characters we had
a bunch of different worlds in trolls
World Tour which was great but it was
very much in the trolls universe or like
what we knew about the trolls
everything's still very fthy and felt
very familiar but in this um movie we
explored you know much bigger creatures
and creatures we had never seen before
and worlds with new textures and and
trying to figure out how could we
reflect that especially in the animation
not just in the textures that we did but
how the characters would move and that
sort of thing and you know we had
studied a bunch of you know 20s and 30s
animation with like rubber hose and that
sort of thing and then even more modern
stuff like Adventure Time and and Steven
Universe and and Wander Over Yonder and
and you know drawing that inspiration
than trying to do something unique and
and still connected to the trolls world
but when it came to like velvet veneer
and and some of those new characters
what were some of the Inspirations
because their look is very different
than what we're accustomed to seeing in
the first two films yeah I think um you
know there were a lot of versions I
think of velvet and veneer over the
course of you know the making of the
film and in the end you know we wanted I
think we wanted something different you
know I mean we wanted something new but
something that yeah the audience hadn't
seen before you know I think good
sequels you know expand the universe you
know show you stuff that you hadn't seen
before but that still feels you know in
the universe that you love we did like
studying a lot of you know uh
contemporary pop stars or or more modern
pop stars for a lot of their uh uh you
know some of their mannerisms and one of
the things we noticed like we were
studying Billy ish you know um and just
seeing some interviews with her and we
noticed that she never said in her chair
normally if that makes you know I mean
it was like either throwing her legs
over the side or she would like sit up
you know like this and and I was like
something I don't know kind of cool
about that or something that felt very
um unique and somehow um you know pop
star that doesn't really you know adhere
to normal social you know um Norms so
all that kind of stuff we just hoped
would would make characters that felt
unique and and uh special to the world
so and not human that was kind of a big
rule for us oh sure cuz we had
storyboarded this velvet veneer
characters and people would be confused
like are they human so we had to push
because there's There are rules in the
troll Universe hard to believe but one
is that there's there are no humans in
that world so by pushing the animation
and pushing the style and doing a little
bit of 1930s flasher Brothers animation
blended with like 1990s pop Divas we get
this unique thing a little bit a yellow
submarine in there lots of yellow submar
okay all right that's nice to see tons
of yellow submarine always weaving uh
psychedelia in there and there's a
history of psychedelic animation going
back to Fantasia up through the uh
Yellow Submarine and then some so
hopefully we're a part of that now yes
you know it's Poppy and Branch you know
furthering their story their evolution
but it's also furthering the story of
Bary Justin Timberlake and and a kentri
because they they played these
characters now for you know seven plus
years so what was that collaboration uh
for you there are a couple that everyone
ships like I think we're all like yes
Poppy and branch and we definitely
talked a lot about where we start them
and where we end them and I think that
we didn't take them so far and there
were definitely versions of the script
where you know maybe they ended a little
farther than they actually ended up in
this version and I think I love watching
them together I love seeing them I love
their small moments I love watching
these two characters evolve over the
movies you know where especially like
pop is a little smarter now she's not
they're not like the arch characters
that they were in that first one and I
love their love and I think that they're
a great couple and that's what's special
I think about making a third part in a
chapter that we get like these
characters are growing up even with some
of the audience so we get to get in
there and have some more complex
emotional architecture on these
characters since we spent time with them
and we work really closely with Justin
and Anna were improvising things as well
and they have a big say and would my
character do that that would they say
this so they're a huge author in this as
well when it comes to this the
screenwriting process for a film like
this do you do you do a pass and then
hear the music and evolve it or do you
do you like in the case of there's like
I think five new songs do you do the
songs come first and then you're able to
weave the story and the screenplay
around the songs like how how is that
process well where are the most pivotal
moments where are where do we need to
carry narrative um and so then Justin
and the team can then write to those
moments but make them pop songs so
they're not too specific that they can't
live on the radio as well but they work
for the movie um in the story in the
narrative and it feels natural in the
script too like you're definitely at a
point you know like in that opening
Montage before the wedding you're like
you want a big medley here you like
we've seen the opening scene you want to
stand up and dance you want that
reprieve like when she meets Viva you
want an original you want like her Hero
song there you want her introduction so
I think they're you know just naturally
writing even before I get you know kind
of directives of where things are going
to go and we're hearing a brand new in
sync song so like everything's great how
how did that come about to unite and see
well it came later in the process you
know I think obviously when we started
working with Justin and recording and
there was this journey of boy bands and
he was he had a really healthy attitude
about it you know we wanted to celebrate
that that era of music but also poke fun
at it and he he has a really fun healthy
attitude but so I think it was what how
many maybe two years in Gina and he
texted you he texted me while I was
walking my dog and he said I think I
found the song for the end and I want to
bring insync back together to do it and
uh so I screamed and and then we talked
on the phone and and then I screamed
again on the phone but um it was yeah it
was amazing the whole process he you
know reached out to the band we pitched
them the story they were all really into
it the biggest covert operation we've
ever had at Dreamworks
Animation um we had only the elite crws
could be on like designing and animating
that thing yeah code words and
everything I bet I mean you can't keep a
secret at all these days it's a miracle
I but I'm also so so when how long ago
do do all the actors record their their
voices pretty early on but it's a lot of
it's a it's a back and forth it's a
constant conversation with Liz and then
getting into our story Department we'll
cut things together we'll do some of the
voices we'll come back we'll record with
Justin and Anna and they'll improv some
things it's just a constant back and
forth but we're always allowing the
voices to dictate the animation in terms
of uh you know you with the with the new
songs and the covers uh how does it all
work to complement Theodore chaparro's
score the music is so diverse it's from
all the different decades especially in
the last film which he worked with him
on that one too all the different genres
and he Blends it all together you can
hear in the score you'll hear some of
the Melodies From the songs and he'll
weave those early in so you don't even
you haven't even heard the song but it's
in your head I mean he's a master he's
so good also in terms of the animation
you know uh your production designer
Ruben Perez yeah uh how does that
collaboration work with animation and
production design so I would say I mean
Ruben basically is one of the first
people that comes in once we have
storyboards that we start pitching we
start putting a reel together of
storyboards of how the sequences are
going to be laid out what's happening in
each sequence and then he takes those
storyboards and takes it with his his uh
Team of of uh designers and artists and
they come back to us and start pitching
ideas it's just this kind of back and
forth of playfulness I think of saying
Hey what if we tried this instead of
what your brain immediately goes to it's
so upbeat it's so positive H it's in you
know I hate to use a word but it's
infectious uh but is this not the right
time for this movie or what it is a
challenging time in the world and it
always has been each release of trolls
we Face some new insurmountable conflict
and trolls comes along to it makes you
feel good like there's real power and
medicine and laughter like they say well
that is for sure it's definitely an
escape to Joy yeah yeah well make sure
that you all escape to Joy and tell
everybody the movie is in theaters
November 17th see it where it belongs on
the big screen and thank you all so much
for being here the Academy's very
special screening of trolls band
together thank you all very much thank
you so much you guys thank
you